Traduttore: SILVIA ALLONE
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Allora, in questi 18 minuti
vi racconterò alcune cose
di cui avrete già sentito parlare,
in parte, in modo più meno approfondito.
Per il resto, invece,
vi parlerò di un'attività
che non potete conoscere,
perché sono esperimenti
che portano avanti i miei
giovani collaboratori, giù a Teramo.
Quello che vedete,
in questa diapositiva alle mie spalle,
è la cover, la web page
di un'associazione che viene chiamate UCN.
La UCN è un'associazione no profit
ed è composta da qualcosa
come 4.0000 scienziati, biologi ecc.,
persone appassionate del pianeta
che vanno in giro per il pianeta;
e quello che fanno è monitorare,
tenere sotto controllo
tutto lo stato di salute del pianeta,
ovviamente andando a contare, censendo
le spese vegetali e le spese animali.
Dopodiché stilano un rapporto,
appunto, annuale,
"Red List" neanche a farlo apposta,
dove vedono gli animali o le piante
che se la passano bene,
quindi in perfetto stato di salute;
gli animali invece il cui numero
si sta riducendo, leggermente minacciati;
oppure gravemente minacciati
di estinzione;
oppure estinte in natura;
ma viventi in bioparchi o zoo;
oppure persa, estinta per sempre.
"Estinta per sempre" vuol dire
che quell'animale non sarà più con noi.
Il problema è estremamente serio:
poco fa ne parlava nella TED film
che abbiamo visto il collega americano,
parlava di cinque estinzioni sul pianeta:
ed in effetti questa è
la quinta estinzione di massa del pianeta.
Ora, mentre sulle precedenti -
a parte quella dei dinosauri,
come sapete causata dell'impatto
della Terra con un asteroide -
non conosciamo i motivi,
Delle estinzioni in corso sappiamo
esattamente chi è il responsabile: noi.
E sappiamo esattamente
delle specie che stanno scomparendo.
L'ultimo censimento parla
di oltre 5.000 specie,
ed essendo veterinario mi preoccupano,
in modo particolare, i mammiferi:
ce ne sono 180 di questi
che stanno scomparendo,
130 di questi sono grossi mammiferi.
Ovviamente vi rendete conto,
che questi numeri da soli parlano
e dicono che il problema
è di grande serietà.
Tanto è vero che, come sapete -
o non so se lo sapete,
ve lo dico adesso io -
le Nazioni Unite hanno indetto
il decennio 2011-2020
"Decennio della biodiversità".
Cosa vogliono fare, con questo?
Vogliono stimolare chi prende le decisioni
a porre più attenzione al problema,
e se possibile trasformare questo
con interventi mirati.
L'altra cosa che senz'altro
sorprenderà buona parte di voi,
[è che] quando parliamo di estinzione,
immediatamente delle icone tipo panda,
piuttosto che la tigre
o il rinoceronte albino,
insomma, vengono nella nostra mente.
E in effetti, non è così.
Stanno scomparendo un numero enorme,
il 20% circa di razze domestiche,
quindi voglio dirvi [che] polli, conigli,
cani, cavalli, bovini, suini
stanno progressivamente scomparendo,
nel senso che vengono rimpiazzati,
scalzati, sostituiti
da specie animali più produttive,
vengono chiamate
"industriali" dai tecnici.
Questo vuol dire
che tante di queste popolazioni,
adattate a condizioni
climatiche, ambientali,
che molto spesso sono all'origine
di prodotti di nicchia,
quindi anche di aspetti culturali,
vanno via, stanno andando via.
Io sono nato in Sardegna,
e quindi mi sono occupato,
indovinate di che cosa, di pecore.
Tu nasci in Sardegna, esci:
ecco, pecore, non potevo fare altro.
E su questi animali ho lavorato,
e sulla sua variante selvatica,
che è il muflone.
Quelle che vedete alle mie spalle
sono le immagini delle razze,
dei progenitori, diciamo così,
delle razze ovine domestiche
che sono allevate intorno al Mediterraneo.
Ora, tutti questi animali
ovviamente stanno scomparendo,
quindi questo è un patrimonio genetico
e culturale secondo me enorme.
Per cui la prima cosa da fare, secondo me,
è lasciare questi animali indisturbati,
non ridurre gli areali anzi amplificarli,
questa è la strategia migliore.
Ci sono però dei particolari casi
in cui bisogna intervenire.
Quando?
Quando le popolazioni animali
scendono oltre un certo numero.
Per esempio,
una popolazione di bovini selvatici
composta da sette femmine e tre maschi,
inevitabilmente va incontro
all'estinzione.
Inevitabilmente.
Si innesca una spirale negativa
per cui si riduce la fertilità,
aumenta la mortalità embrionale
e l'animale se ne va.
In questo caso è possibile
che un tecnico come me,
che si occupa di embrioni,
di tecnologie embrionali,
possa dare il suo contributo.
Come?
Beh, senz'altro vi è a tutti familiare
il concetto della Dolly,
la pecora clonata.
Essenzialmente si prende un ovocita,
una cellula uovo,
si svuota dei propri cromosomi,
che vengono sostituiti
da questa cellula differenziata -
una cellula per la pelle per esempio,
e qui faccio questo copia-incolla
e ho da dieci animali mille, diecimila,
quindi spostando il rischio
dell'estinzione di questi animali.
La cosa interessante
è che questa tecnologia della clonazione
non riguarda più i mammiferi;
hanno clonato tutte le specie domestiche,
anche gli animali da compagnia;
ma si possono clonare degli insetti,
dei pesci, delle rane,
questo lo abbiamo sempre fatto,
per cui è una tecnologia trasversale,
estremamente interessante,
che possiamo applicare
a tutte le specie animali.
Il problema.
Innanzitutto, come si fa?
Due cenni tecnici di microchirurgia,
non voglio tediarvi con questo.
Quello che vedete è una cellula-uovo,
sono tutte così nei mammiferi,
vengono immobilizzate,
insomma con dei capillari di vetro;
dopodiché si tolgono i cromosomi,
sono questi che vedete, dei puntini blu,
dopodiché viene fecondata questa
cellula-uovo da una cellula somatica,
inizia lo sviluppa embrionale
e abbiamo l'animale.
Il problema qual è?
Il problema è che non
funziona ancora bene,
è una tecnologia
assolutamente sperimentale.
Non conosciamo quello che facciamo,
l'efficienza è bassissima:
dovete produrre cento embrioni
per avere un animale,
per cui stiamo lavorando affinché
questa tecnica diventi affidabile,
"risk-free", come si dice oggi:
nel frattempo, però,
quello che bisogna fare è iniziare,
come degli autorevoli scienziati
stanno facendo,
a raccogliere delle linee cellulari
di questi animali
prima che sia troppo tardi.
Questo è quello che si sta chiedendo,
sempre più insistentemente,
alla comunità scientifica,
ma anche alla gente comune.
E in effetti,
chiunque si occupi di queste cose
ha la sua banchettina.
Anche noi,
quando arriva al laboratorio
un animale particolare,
un camoscio appenninico per esempio,
prendo e se sono spermatozoi li congelo.
Quindi tutti noi, piano piano,
diciamo, artigianalmente,
stiamo allestendo queste banche.
Pochi sono gli sforzi,
come quello che vedete alle mie spalle,
invece, più organizzati, diciamo così,
di conservare questo materiale.
Queste cellule vengono conservate
come vengono conservate tutte le cellule:
si mettono in un medium
e si tengono congelate in azoto liquido.
L'azoto liquido a 196 C° sotto zero.
Freddissimo.
Funziona bene.
Le tecniche sono robuste, affidabili:
voi congelate, scongelate,
il 70 percento delle cellule
che avete congelato sopravvive.
Dove sono i problemi?
I problemi sono i costi,
perché l'azoto liquido costa produrlo,
ha un impatto ambientale
perché vengono prodotte
tante tonnellate di CO2.
L'altro problema
è che il 70 percento
degli animali di cui vi ho parlato
vive in Africa,
e lì l'azoto liquido
è veramente costoso, poco probabile.
Allora ho iniziato a chiedermi
si può fare qualcosa,
qualche soluzione più economica
che possa consentirci di espandere
queste banche genetiche? Esiste?
E adesso anch'io vi porto indietro
di 2.000 anni fa circa,
perché oltre l'embrionologia,
una grande passione che emerge
sempre più è l'archeologia.
E io vi porto in Israele, nel 76 d.C.
I romani hanno conquistato Israele
e distrutto il tempio,
e hanno assediato, nell'altura di Masnada,
una tribù ebraica
composta da 250 individui.
Hanno formato il campo,
lo vedete lì alla sinistra,
hanno lanciato il loro assedio
e dopodiché, dopo due anni, vanno su;
ma tutti gli ebrei
avevano commesso suicidio
e non avevano trovato nulla.
La ragazza, vedete,
della diapositiva a destra,
è l'archeologa
che ha partecipato agli scavi
e lì ha trovato diverse manciate
di semi di datteri
e ha fatto quello che avrei fatto io,
che avremmo fatto tutti noi:
prendiamo questi datteri,
mettiamoli in un vasetto, diamo acqua
e sorprendentemente sono nate
delle palme dopo 2.000 anni.
Questa è una cosa straordinaria.
Vuol dire che il DNA
è straordinariamente stabile.
Ho iniziato ad occuparmi di questa storia
e mi sono guardato intorno:
secondo me basta studiare bene
tutto ciò che ci circonda,
e la natura ha già provveduto
a tutto quanto.
Questo è un animale
che si chiama tardigrado:
sono degli animali strani,
di circa un millimetro di lunghezza.
[Se] piove, si idratano,
vivono sulle tegole
e hanno questa vita loro.
Insomma, non è un granché presumo.
(Applauso)
Non c'è più acqua? Vive allo stato anidro.
Progressivamente cedono acqua,
si disidratano,
assumono l'aspetto che vedete
e se ne stanno buoni:
una settimana, due settimane,
cento giorni, anni.
Se piove di nuovo,
reiniziano questa loro bella vita.
Qual è il segreto di questi animali?
Non l'ho scoperto io,
dei colleghi che ci lavorano
hanno scoperto
che questi animali riescono a sopravvivere
perché producono uno zucchero
chiamato trealosio,
il quale protegge
queste cellule dal dessiccamento.
Ho detto: fantastico.
Allora facciamo così:
chiamo un amico israeliano,
perché ho capito
che le cose secche durano a lungo,
e ho detto: liofilizziamo le cellule
per poi utilizzare
queste cellule liofilizzate
per fare il copy and paste,
il copia e incolla della clonazione.
E lui in effetti,
liofilizzava le cellule con il trealosio
e me le mandava via posta a Teramo.
Ovviamente era complicato,
perché tutte le volte
dovevo spiegare che -
è una polvere bianca
(Risate)
e sembra veramente cocaina.
Quando dicevo che non era cocaina,
ma erano cellule liofilizzate,
il veterinario mi riteneva
un totale cretino,
e mi diceva: smetti di fare questo,
perché non porta a nessuna parte.
Ho preso queste cellule,
le abbiamo iniettate -
non ho fatto io questo lavoro,
l'ha fatto un giapponese
che lavorava con noi -
e queste cellule dopo cinque anni,
tenute secche come avete visto,
io uso un termine forte,
sono state resuscitate dall'ovocita
e hanno avviato lo sviluppo embrionale
dopo cinque anni.
Abbiamo ripetuto l'esperimento
dopo otto anni,
e continuano ad essere vive.
Questo è straordinario.
Prima di tutto,
io non potevo credere a quello che vedevo,
ma neanche le ditte:
ci abbiamo messo due anni,
per pubblicare questo lavoro.
Per fortuna, adesso
lo hanno ripetuto degli altri
su altri animali, maiale e quant'altro,
e la cosa è stabilita.
Questo è il prodotto finito,
anzi me ne son portato anche una fiala.
Eccole qua.
Prodotto finito, giuro,
cellule liofilizzate e non altro.
(Applauso)
Allora ovviamente noi
andiamo ancora avanti,
perché insomma, io voglio capire
come far meglio ancora.
Il DNA vegetale e il DNA animale
sono gli stessi, ovviamente,
non c'è nessuna differenza.
In questo modo siamo riusciti
a tenere vivo il nucleo,
però la cellula no;
e allora i campioni
della longevità sono i semi.
Andando a fondo, ho scoperto
che hanno fatto germinare
semi di una pianta, si chiama lupino,
dopo 35 mila anni.
35 mila anni secchi, e poi...
Quello che stiamo facendo,
è una cosa molto semplice:
facciamo esprimere queste proteine,
si chiamano Lea,
è un acronimo che è un nome di donna;
e stiamo utilizzando queste proteine
per migliorare le performance
della liofilizzazione delle cellule.
Di questo spero,
l'anno venturo o tra due anni,
di raccontarvi cose
più interessanti, se riusciamo.
Questo è il lavoro
che facciamo in laboratorio,
sul campo
le cose stanno andando avanti.
Lì in Israele,
questa è una gazzella israeliana,
che prima, lo dice anche la Bibbia,
abbondava da quelle parti,
e adesso si è ridotta
a qualche decina di capi.
Quello che vedete in basso a destra
è il collega veterinario
che si sta occupando
di questo salvataggio genetico,
va in giro nel deserto.
Questa che vedete è una razza
che si chiama Barbery,
è una razza di pecore
che vive intorno a Jerico.
Allora, intorno a Jerico
l'allevamento ovino è iniziato
circa 12.000 anni fa.
Questo è un progenitore di queste razze,
presente in numeri ridottissimi.
Quindi quello che stiamo facendo
è cercare un po' di allestire
queste banche genetiche.
Poi questo è il prodotto finito.
Le fiale sono quelle là
sono un pochino più eleganti.
Sono più carine queste,
quelle sono risultati bellici,
sono strani come le organizzano.
E la cosa più curiosa è che
questa idea è stata passata,
gli israeliani sono straordinari,
hanno una mentalità
imprenditoriale sviluppatissima.
E quindi questo collega israeliano
ha preso la Bibbia.
Adesso ritorniamo della Bibbia,
chissà perché ho trovato
tanti interventi che parlano di questo.
È andato nel Vecchio Testamento,
voi sapete che contiene
tutte le istruzioni,
dimensionali, lunghezza, larghezza,
scompartimenti, materiali di partenza
per produrre l'arca;
e ha costruito un'arca
nel deserto israeliano,
dove stanno mettendo
queste cellule liofilizzate.
Quando ero un ragazzino,
leggendo la Bibbia,
io trovavo estremamente difficile capire
come noi avessimo potuto
incastrare là dentro
elefanti, coccodrilli e tutto il resto,
perché era complicato viste le dimensioni.
Adesso invece, vedete,
qua ci sono qualcosa come 250 milioni
di cellule di pecora Barbery,
in questa Arca di Noè.
Veramente io sono confidente, sono sicuro
che là dentro ci possono stare
tutti gli animali,
in via di estinzione e non,
di questo pianeta.
(Applausi)